[音楽]
[拍手]
今日の私の話はあなたが社会を変えるには
ですえ皆さんには解体社会課題があります
かデッド世代の9割が社会課題に関心を
持っているというデータがあり
ます地球温暖化少子化女性の社会格差
世の中課題だらけですよ
ね私には解体社会があり
ます世界では1億6000万人の子供が
働いていますえここに映っているのは西
アフリカのシエラリオネ強国ですこの国で
は児童労働による子供の教育格差が深刻
です日本ではほぼ100%の人が義務教育
完了できますでもシエラネでは約2割が
達成できませ
ん変えないといけない社会がありますでは
社会を変えられる人ってどんな人たち
でしょうかえスティーブジョブスですか
マザーテルサですかえこんな人たちを
思い浮かべるかもしれませんでも実は皆
さんも社会を変えられる人なん
です実は社会を変えるために崇高な挑戦力
や使命感は必要ではありません私には長年
の経験から会えたある知見があります社会
を変えるには声を上げ仲間を
集めたくさんの人に課題に共感してもらい
社会の常識を変えることです今日は本の
些細な出来事でもいいので買いたいなと
思った社会について思いを馳せてみて
くださいえその上で私が社会を変えるため
の具体的なメソッドを皆さんにお伝えする
ので覚えて実践してみて欲しいです
具体的な社会を変えるミソを皆さんにお
伝えする前に私が社会を変えたいと強く
思ったきっかけについて紹介させて
ください私は幼少期母子家庭で生活保護を
もらって生きていまし
た当時の生活保護ってエアコン使っちゃ
いけなかったんです夏は暑くて冬は寒かっ
た
です家族で旅行に行ったこともないし遊園
地も行ったことなかったです周りと比べて
寂しいと思うことが多い幼少期でし
たところが中学校2年生で母が再婚します
父ができましたで父ができるとなんと大学
に行けることになりました大学に行け
るって思ってなかった
ですそして明るい未来が見えてきた高校2
年生の時にテレビでたまたま西アフリカの
シエラレオネ共和国について知ります
シエラレネでは私が生まれた1991年
から2002年まで11年間にも及ぶ内戦
が繰り広げられていまし
たえしかも私たち先進国の人々が婚約指輪
として送るダイヤモンドの原石が武器取引
に利用されて戦争が長引いてたん
です反政府軍に両親を目の前で殺された8
歳の男の子君のドキュメンタリーでし
た彼は着るものも食べるものもない中1日
中兄弟を養うために児童労働をしていまし
たえ番組スタッフが彼に何か欲しいもの
あると聞きますすると彼は何と答えたと
思いますか勉強したいと言ったんですその
一言が忘れられなくなりまし
た母が再婚して突然大学に行けことになっ
て明るい未来から切り開いた私は彼の状況
に痛いほど共感しまし
たそして大学卒業後の24歳で就職をせず
にシエラレオネに渡航することを開始し
ますえところが初めて行ったシエラレオネ
の現状には真底を打ちのめされましたえ
まず食べ物が合わないんですねでお腹壊し
てるし熱も出るしもう言葉も分からない
自分1人が何かしたぐらいでは現状変え
られなさそうな貧困を当たりにしましたえ
無力ですし悔しかった
です
そして私の動に対する周りの反対も
凄まじかったです私自身生活費歩行費ワチ
内借金が増え続けるばかりの時にこの活動
やめようかなとも思いましたやらなきゃ
いけないことやるべきだと思っていたもの
のさにがついたん
ですでも私は諦めたくありませんでし
た続けられる根拠はないけどSNSでの
発信はやめてませんでした人と会う機会を
作り続けてましたえそうするとだんだんと
仲間が集まってきましたえそしてある日
仲間を集めて私が高校2年生の時に見た
ドキュメンタリー番組をもう1度見る機会
を作りましたえそこで私は気がついたん
です私は使命感や怒りだけで行動していた
わけではなくなってました私はいつからか
シエラレオネの魅力そのものを仲間に発信
してたん
ですシエラレオネで出会った人々国民性
そしてこの活動で出会う仲間との日々が
大好きで夢中になってることに気づきまし
た夢中になってることに気づくと周りの
行動にも変化が訪れました
え仲間たちがこの活動を自分ごとして周り
に発信してくれるようになったん
です1人じゃないことに気づいて可能性に
溢れてワクワクしました夢中になってる
ことに対して必然的に仲間が応援して
くくれるようになりまし
たそして私たちは仲間と協力してNPO
法人アジを作りまし
た今私たちはシエラリオネ際国で最も教育
を置き続けることが困難な子供たち述べ
2000人に教育の機会を提供してい
ますもうきづきかと思い
ます私たちはゼロから始めて社会を変える
ことができたん
ですやらなきゃいけないことじゃなくて
本当にやりたいことを選択
する使命感や挑戦力ではなく夢中になれる
ことこそが社会を変えてくん
ですでは皆さんが夢中になって社会を変え
たいと思った時にどうやって声をあげて
仲間を集めて課題に共感してもらって社会
の常識を変えていけばいいんでしょうか
ここからは私が信頼と実績もない中で多く
の人から根拠なく応援され社会を変える人
になれた4つのメソッドを皆さんに紹介し
ますえ1つ目は発信すること
ですできれば正体を明かして発信して
ください
最初は信頼と実績がないからなかなか仲間
が集まらないでも発信は無料ででき
ます夢中になってることに対して発信を
続けてるとだんだん人が集まってきますえ
2つ目は仲間の共感を呼ぶことですえ1人
で完璧にしようとしなくていいんです苦手
なこと失敗しちゃったこと隠さずに発信し
てください素直に助けてと言える視点に
仲間がだんだん集まってきます仲間が仲間
を呼んでくれる状態にするために心理的
安全性を保つことも重要ですえ様々な参加
のコミット度の人たちがいますえ様々に
参加の窓を用意してそして彼らが発信者に
なる仕掛けを作り続けることで課題への
共感差が生まれ続け
ますえ3つ目は同業他者とのネットワー
ング
です同じ社会課題に取り組む企業
NPOそれから行政様々なステーク
ホルダーとの共同で社会を良くしていき
ますこれをコレクティブインパクトと言い
ますえ1つの団体だけでは地球上全ての
課題を解決するの難しい
です1つの組織に収入が集中するような形
ではなく仲間の共有ノウハウの共有
あらゆる資業の共有で課題解決が早く進み
ますえそして最後はチェンジメーカーとの
出会いですえここまで来ると課題の現状を
変えられる権限を持つ人えつまりチェンジ
メーカーと出会えるようになっていますえ
どんなにいい活動ミッションビジョンを
掲げていても活動を始めたばかりで社会の
現状をき変えることは難しいですえ社会を
変えるためにはチェンジメーカーの指示を
終えて社会の常識を変える必要があり
ます私たちにとってのチェンジメーカーは
シエラレネ現地のケの教育者のトップの人
でした彼女にアクセスしてきたことで
私たちのプログラムの重要性が社会に浸透
して子供たちの教育支援の可能性がぐっと
広がりましたえここまでのメソッドを
用いると皆さんも解体社会の実現に大きく
近づくはずですNPOという手段じゃなく
ても実践できると思い
ますえさて夢中になれることを見つける
ことが難しいとと思う人もいるかもしれ
ませ
んでも実は皆さんは夢中になれることに
出会う選択肢に溢れています努力できる
こと勉強できることえこれはとっても贅沢
なことで決して世界のスタンダードでは
ありませ
ん皆さんが生まれながらにして努力でき
勉強できるチャンスを生かして諦めずに
探し続けてれば必ず夢中になれることが
見つかると思い
ますえ最後に社会を買い始めた私にはでき
ないえ皆さんにしかできないことを紹介し
て終わり
ますそれは皆さんが知った課題をご友人や
ご家族にお話しすること
ですえ実は私のことをWebで検索する人
はすでに課題に関心がある人なん
です私のことをSNSで見かける人も
アルゴリズムで選ばれたすでに課題に関心
がある人です
私は課題のこと全く知らない人に
アプローチすることが難しいん
ですですから皆さんが今日知った世界の
教育の課題夢中になれることで社会を変え
られることを皆さんの古からのご友人やご
家族に是非お話ししてくださいまた次の誰
かが夢中になれることに出会うきっかけに
なるかもしれませんえ社会を変えるにはえ
声をあげ仲間を集めえ課題に共感して
もらいそして社会の常識を変えること
です皆さんにも社会は変えられます未来に
向かって突っ走って
ください